hello and welcome back to the corridor
cast today's episode is sponsored by the
book the official book top 10 games you
can play in your head by yourself edited
by our very own Sam Gorski and our buddy
d/f Lovett this book is available right
now on Amazon so there's a little if
you're watching this there's a link in
the description otherwise go to corridor
digital dot-com and there'll be a link
at the top of our website
that's right it's available now it's
finally here turn your mind into the
ultimate gaming engine and with that our
guest today we have the honor of hosting
Wes was good Armstrong who is a creator
and director who's seen it all and done
it all you may recognize his work from
oh I don't know YouTube Facebook vine
Instagram he has gotten to work with
some of the greatest comedians currently
out there on on the digital mediums he's
gotten to work with a bunch of big names
in music doing music videos and we're
gonna hear his story and how he went
from having $20 in his pocket when he
first moved to Los Angeles to amassing
over 1 point 7 million followers on
Facebook and almost another million on
Instagram so what goes into that what
goes into the man who can amass that
following for himself and what's his
creative style like we're gonna find out
all about it right here right now
welcome back to the corridor digital
podcast we got Wes was good Armstrong
here thanks for being here man dude
thank you for having me he you just come
in to do a little cameo yeah one of our
videos first time yeah about time it's
about it tickets took us like three
years to get together on 3:15 yeah for
years 2019 oh my hand time flies
it does dude but it's awesome I'm so
excited because you guys have the best
channel on YouTube oh you heard it here
first you heard it here first
seriously well that's I think what
brought us here is that you came down to
our studio with a couple buddies a
couple years ago and and we just had
sort of this mutual admiration
for the work that yeah that we were
doing and so you know I think that's
throughout throughout the last four
years I've been searching like say oh
maybe we could get on this or maybe we
kitchen on that and you know one has
time yeah you know because it's why is
there not enough hours in the day like
24 is just like we only have honestly we
only have about I want to say a good
eight you're gonna be good eight yeah
and it's just like that's not enough you
got a sleeping aid and why is sleep why
I think sleep is so wack I'll be mad
every time I lay down I go to sleep I'm
like well I say it's because we have
these big old brains that's why we have
to sleep so much I need I need I need a
surrogate that you can like operate
Wallace get stuff done let me dream low
and we ran out of somebody else yeah
yeah or or like just listen I think
corridor e I think you guys have the
technology somewhere in this building to
duplicate I think you do we do we do
please oh man so yeah I'd like let's
just tell us tell us a little bit about
how you got started in all this cuz I
mean you've been doing this for how many
years now directing writing creating
over over ten years now yeah but uh I
just say it started I started when I was
in my mom I just know honestly like I
started out in radio well prior to that
I grew up in Japan really yes I grew up
in Japan and that influenced a ton of
what's going on in my life when I moved
back to the states I was 18 and you know
I was just kind of like terrified of the
world but I knew I wanted to be in the
industry somehow so when I went to
college I got on the radio that's how I
got the name was good but that wasn't
enough yeah I was you know even though I
was talent I was like there's another
level you know I need to be in front the
camera so I found the school in Florida
by name a full sail and I got a brochure
and they just sent me packages for an
entire year and I was like I'm going to
that school
and I'm going to work from behind the
camera to get in front you know I was
like that's the only way I'll be able to
do it yeah and I went out there with the
intentions to be an editor and then I
found out how much work that was and I
was like yeah no I'm not doing that
and I started directing and there was a
teacher at my school
he said film is 24 frames so if you can
get his still frame down you'll be able
to nail 24 so I started with photography
yeah and I literally shot everything you
know bus benches doorknobs sidewalks
just trying to find different
perspective knowing my lenses and then I
eventually got into directing and I
photography took me pretty far I did
album covers I did magazine covers I was
working with a ton of artists I used to
take my business cards and leave it
every place I'd go to the Apple store
and I typed my website in on every
computer and I just leave it's just any
way to get my name out there and this
really popular producer at the time and
said find an artist in your town I was
in Orlando Florida that's the biggest
one and do a video for them and I did a
I did a music video for this group
called trill and the video went up on
WorldStarHipHop and that was really
popular at the time and did a million
views and I thought I was going to be
rich I was like that's it I'm out the
game God everything is going to be
expensive sorry I know my worth guys and
that was just pre understanding what the
internet what this world was about I you
know at that time I was in a
relationship that didn't end up working
out and I just end up becoming homeless
and I was couchsurfing for like the next
two years after doing that video the
video first of all it took like five
months to do because crew members were
dropping off like flies you know there
was no budget
I was just me and my buddy were like
Jelena shoot a video and we did it and
you know it did it did well on the
internet but that doesn't mean anything
you know when artists are trying to work
with you I just over priced myself you
know and like that's just me not knowing
too much about
industry I'm just like you yeah you guys
can't afford it like I know you want to
give me $5,000 but it's gonna cost
$15,000 for me to do anything you know
or you know I was just I was just over
pricing myself completely and that put
me in just a big hole and then I my
neighbor was like hey I'm moving to LA
on Monday do you want to go and I had 20
bucks I was sleeping on my friend's
couch so I asked my roommate
do you want to go to LA on Monday and he
was like yeah let's go so we drove from
Orlando to LA and it was on the pretense
of going to a meeting I did have a
meeting with this producer I was
supposed to be doing projects with and
that you know like me being not not
really that knowledgeable about how LA
works you know like that meeting was
just you know something to say
it was nothing in jokes yeah and it was
nothing scheduled it was just like yeah
let's do a meeting we get to LA so we
drove there I was like yeah we're gonna
have a meeting on Wednesday this is me
scheduling it for him yeah this is a
huge producer yeah and uh that meeting
was not even on their schedule or their
radar at all so I called my friends and
they allowed me stay on their couch so
now I'm in LA sleeping on another couch
and I'm like this is around the time
when my space was really popular YouTube
was just now budding but what I would do
was any video that I had I would I'd go
and post it I'd cut reels together all
the time and I'd post it on everyone's
patient this would be my job from 9:00
to 5:00 I'd send videos yeah visual fire
check out new visual fire and I'd have
like a compilation of music videos that
I did ha 10 how did you get the footage
for all that oh I mean I shot I I did a
lot of videos yeah I did a lot of videos
like the one big one led to other videos
even though I overpriced they were like
videos in between yeah but it just
wasn't enough to sustain
you know neither were word photography
geeks they were like small cakes but I
was shooting a lot of big artists at the
time yeah so a lot of a lot of the times
it's I still think today it's about the
illusion you know in order to get the
bigger gigs you know so it was a lot a
lot of sacrifice just hoping to pray and
then a lot of stuff is gonna really pop
off let's uh let's unpack all this a
little bit look pre pre arriving at La
Brea arriving I mean you started this
conversation by saying you grew up in
Japan yes so unbox that for me man cuz
I've never grown up there so my mom is a
marine okay um and when I was in third
grade
she got orders to go to Okinawa Japan
and I was like hell no I don't want to
go there I have friends here right and
mom yeah exactly mom and we moved over
there and it was it was just the oddest
thing at first you know you go there and
there's about seven eight military bases
there and there's Marine Corps bases and
there's like I think one Air Force Base
and we moved to this base called Kinser
and I went to this elementary school and
I met all these new kids and they
introduced me to like Dragon Ball Z
because it wasn't out in the States it
was I was on Power Rangers when I moved
over there and then I got interested
Ragan Ball Z and it was just I was just
in love with that show and I'm still him
to this day and I continued I started
doing martial arts and got my black belt
in Okinawa Kempo got another black belt
in Taekwondo yeah and yeah made great
friends some of my best friends over
there and I left my senior year of high
school
so you were all you were with a bunch of
other military kids yeah so it was like
I grew up on like I'm around a melting
pot of cultures right so everyone was
mixed with Japanese Native American
Korean and German Filipino and Taiwanese
there was like everything there yeah so
it was really hard you know like I think
when your military kid you want to
identify with some memory or maybe where
your parents were from in the States so
when people asked where you from I was
like yeah I'm from New York
you know I'd try to have
fake New York accent like I know nothing
about in here actually I was terrified
in New York at the time because my mom
is from Brooklyn and my my family
they're all West Indian so we have
Barbados and monsterettes Oh heard
growing up in New York that's what I
related my life to at the time and when
I terrifying for anyone I feel yeah yeah
it's definitely hard and as a kid you're
just like what the heck yeah so yeah we
were in Japan Japan was like when I left
it was probably the hardest thing like I
didn't want to leave I didn't want to
leave and it was a culture shock coming
back to the States was the was the like
so many things was the best thing about
living there best thing about living in
Japan the culture the Japanese culture
is so dope they're so advanced I you
know just from from the video games like
video games are coming out or there's so
much stuff coming out early but there
were so much stuff coming out late like
the disadvantage at the time was we
didn't get cable and we got movies like
six months late so I'd come back to talk
to my cousins and my friends I'd like
yell did you see this like yeah that
came out last year okay oh oh okay you
don't like that do you no no no they
everything's you know with the internet
everything's so much more advanced like
when we got cable we didn't get cable to
like three years later and that was for
the entire island of Japan like they
didn't have cable from the states till I
think maybe 97 but like 93 to like 96 it
was three channels one American two or
three Japanese for us on base I'm pretty
sure Japanese had cable but we weren't
getting that so it was it was honestly
the best time of my life though I
learned to drive over there I drove on
the other side of the road on the other
side of the wheel yeah you know coming
back to the states you know is a
complete readjustments of culture shock
and that's weird because you're around a
bunch of people that speak English but
you know come in the States it was just
intimidating from going to the gym like
I never had to pay to go to a gym before
you have to do that here right going to
a pharmacy you moved from from there
directly to Florida no I moved from
there to North Carolina okay
and that's another military base so I
finished out my senior year of high
school in North Carolina at this base
called Camp Lejeune and you know it's
crazy about Japan when you grow up we
grew up in a military family
you always run into someone that you've
known so I was running into people that
I knew from seventh grade or fifth grade
at Lejeune high school Mike Holly yeah
man we used to hang out and you know
like some of my best friends from sixth
grade they lived in North Carolina so it
was crazy to see them and that carried
on even to this day like in college I
moved to Texas to go to college so I
went to Amarillo College in West Texas
A&M where I started at radio that's how
I got the name was good yeah and um will
end up happening I remember I work I had
a job at Walmart I had some regular jobs
in the States that I'm just so glad I'm
not working at anymore yeah I worked at
Domino's Pizza yeah when I was my senior
high school and I suck as a as an
employee outside the industry I remember
like I would just people would call the
phones that the phones are drink so much
at Domino's and I was on the phones I'd
pick up and I would just I would be
exhausted from picking up the phones and
I would say we had this little script
there we have to read the specials and
I'm like thank you for calling Domino's
Pizza this is Wes would you like to hear
about our specials and I don't know if
they're not paying attention I don't
know if I didn't enunciate but they'd be
like no can I hear about your specials
and this is like maybe the 200th call I
had yeah and I just be like just hang
out yeah I'm tapped out
and then they called yeah I think that's
because people have such a what do you
call like a reaction to like pulling up
or calling into a place to order and
then immediately asking you something to
upsell you man it's like because I feel
like I do that sometimes it's like I
pull up to a drive-through and then
can I doubt it a lot and you're like no
yeah here's my order even if it's the
same thing that they just brought they
just said yeah exactly right
it was just man I remember uh the the
other thing that would happen was all
right this is the other phone call sorry
so then they'd call back and the camera
would be on me so I'm like I'm I don't
want to deal with this call so I just be
like and they be like hello hello and
then then they move me to food and I'm a
snacker I'm the type of person that like
I'll have snacks in my house and I won't
eat them home the pepperonis oh man and
I was worse but if I'm at somebody
else's house I'm trying to snack I don't
know why but like I'd be down the line
they're like West don't eat the food I
couldn't help it it was just like these
just seemed like edible all right eat so
boom what so you did all that
yeah wound up you found yourself in a
radio station yes how did you get into
that gig um I went to college in Texas I
heard this girl DJ KC on the radio and I
was like that sounds kind of tight I
think I could do that and I found out
this is like recámara to write this is a
free sample his pre camera I found out
about it and I started uh I started
doing radio I was interning at first and
then I got on the real radio station and
I made my buddy this is when myspace
officially started like I feel like for
me it was like 2004-2005 yeah we started
creating videos and putting up on
YouTube an engineer said you should
check out Full Sail University because
I'm editing these videos I'm just having
fun with my friends editing videos I was
like I felt like I was so advanced but I
was not advanced at all I was on I think
I'll sound like movie makers yeah I
think I was a movie maker and I was like
oh maybe I need a green screen I don't
know where I got the idea for a green
screen I've never seen anything like it
but I was like yeah we're gonna be like
flying I had always had these advanced
ideas that I could never like when I
look back there's no way I could ever
achieve it but like I had the
imagination for it yeah
and so I found out I well before I went
to Full Sail I went to this I went I did
an internship at Disney World
and I went there because having a
martial arts background I was like all
Disney owns Power Rangers so I'm gonna
try and be a Power Ranger so I went out
there for that or part character I
didn't get any of them and I didn't get
in from because you had to know how to
dance and I just don't know how to dance
I don't know choreography it's just not
my skill set so boom I'm there and they
stick me in a fast food good God and
like I I just could not I couldn't deal
with it it was just it was too much like
dealing with that doesn't mean there's
certain things that you have to do you
have to go out they when you're when
you're on the floor they call it being
on stage you have to be out there with a
smile if you're not out there with a
smile you can get written up you can't
point one finger you have to point with
two or this there's like this because
this can disrespect people and in some
cultures so so I'm there for like five
months but I met some great friends
there I just I just couldn't work there
you know so I came back to States did
the radio found out he took I came back
with videos and that's when he told me
about Full Sail and I was like alright a
year later I'm back in Orlando Florida
attending Full Sail University and at
what point did did you first put a
camera in your hands
throughout this oh well I was putting a
camera in my hands when I was doing my
space videos I was sitting there editing
those myself and I think they were like
I thought they were great and there it's
the 4:3 and it's grainy and I'm lighting
and I thought I was making magic right I
thought I was making magic so boom I'm
at full sail and it is like what's the
best place in the world product before I
say Disney it's the best place in the
world like that was it for me think this
is where I need to be and I was just
surrounded by so many driven and
creative people and not so driven and
creative people you know like you start
out with a class of 100 and it breaks
down to like 30 because people are just
dropping off letter
yeah and so like full sales an
accelerated course so you had four hours
lecture eight hour lab or four hour
lecture four hours lab and we were going
through anything from screenwriting to
cinematography to directing to shooting
on a film 35 and 16 millimeter
photography developing film it was just
it was just dope and I had like a you
know I learned really about networking
and so I connected with a bunch of
teachers and they helped me with
shooting projects I remember my senior
project I could show you my senior
project you want to see that way yeah it
was for Rockstar Energy Drink okay and I
found out that you know it was a great
commercial but I learned a valuable
lesson about putting the product and in
the commercial at least three times yeah
and I didn't really have any closed lips
of the product but it was like I had
everyone come out so like a full so
there's so many different degree
programs you have music music you have
show production you have digital art
design you have production design and
yet filmmaking and most black people
that are there are in music so it was
when people asked me oh you're in music
I was like no I'm a filmmaking they're
like oh [ __ ] that's crazy
you know like I don't know why but
that's just how it was their supply and
demand I guess yeah yeah and I was just
I was crazy about you know making dope
stuff so that was that with that you
were able to hook up with people who are
doing music yeah start making music yes
exactly
and I would take pictures of the artists
and you know just I was really into I
got into Lightroom at the time so my
image is when I kind of like cartoony
but nobody else was doing it so that oh
wow this is crazy like what are you
doing I was like I'm just using my
presets that I made so yeah I was on
lightroom heavy I ended up working with
this company at the time called ozone
magazine and they're really popular in
Atlanta and Florida and so I started to
doing photos a pitbull DJ Khaled b.o.b
Ace Hood like all these rappers and
artists that I'm meeting and I was like
you know what I you know the one of the
goals at the time was to get me
iced out chain and a grill I don't know
why but then you find out it's just it's
like all smoke and mirrors so it's just
sometimes it's not what it seems like
you know there's a new artist and you're
thinking oh wow they have all this money
you know like this is gonna you know
they're gonna pay me a lot of money to
do my thing but it's it's it's an
investment for the manager or the label
for the artist so this is some of the
stuff might not be paid off or maybe
this stuff is just for the video like
you know video advance
yeah exactly exactly but you don't know
that going into you thinking like wow
they're coming out they're about to blow
up they're rich already like right I
don't know how it worked you know I
don't understand the business end of
things they used to do that with those
No Limit albums remember they used to do
all the the CG like gold and man yeah
and you're like yo they're on ya you
know but it you know just like any
business it takes time to ramp up and so
that that was like you know a lesson I
had to learn so music videos I'm
traveling around doing music videos well
I'm I graduated school I'm doing music
videos within Florida moved to LA and
then I started getting music videos back
in Florida so now I'm flying back and
forth and then finally I just stay there
another year it was a it was tough but I
I somehow made it out of it my end up
getting a job at Buena Marie so this is
my first job working with a actual like
television studio so they produce
Kardashians of real worlds and stuff
like that but I was over in the digital
department a fellow Full Sail grad got
me the job so I came in as a producer on
the show for a YouTube show
it was kind of like it's called
breakdown and I worked there for like
two years and in that time it was when
YouTube was like going like this so this
is 2012
yeah 2012 YouTube is just on the rise
and in-between the whole 2011 2011 -
it's like 2013 I think that's when it
was like really like go yeah that's yeah
that's when anybody can jump in yeah and
everyone was like blowing up so they I
was shot two shows every day
Monday through Friday and then I started
creating my own shows and around that
time between that time I did a series I
did a short film a spider-man short film
that blew up on the internet it blew up
I didn't meet Marvel execs I mean screen
gem execs like the CEO or president at
the time I met him of Marvel have Screen
Gems okay and then they took it down
like I went to Comic Con and I was like
what do you guys think about taking like
comic books and making dude the short
spider-man film that I did was Miles
Morales alright and this is right when
the comic drop I was like oh I love this
character this is so dope let me make a
short film about this so I went to
comic-con and there's like you know the
project had been out maybe three weeks
and there's a whole line to talk to
people on the Marvel panels and I went
up there and I asked him was like what
do you guys think about you know taking
comic books and making live-action
pieces out of it they're like we don't
mind that all we think actually think
that's great nobody's really doing that
at the time and I think I think there
was superhero beat down I think they
were starting to do theirs but no one
was making like short films out of them
I don't think anyway yeah but um I told
him about that and the whole crowd
erupted I can't even I was like 400
people inside there were so many people
and they're like you made that that's
been circulating around our office for
weeks like come up here we got to talk
to you and I'm taking pictures with them
and I hate that great contact it was I
was like oh I'm about to make it I
thought I was like this is crazy
Brian Michael Bendis retweeted it it was
like it was just a great time and then
ended up being taken down for copyright
infringement
goddamn and I was just like I'm kidding
me so I put a little disclaimer in front
of it and uploaded it again and then
it's then it's still there to this day
it didn't I didn't get back to a million
but whatever and then a vine came out
yeah and I got introduced to in fact
well I think 2013 okay I think 2013 I
got introduced to it in February my
friend Ken Michaels I go you should
check out this app I think you could do
really well
yeah and I was like oh man it's over
it's over and then I didn't touch it I
didn't touch it for like six months and
then well let me and also in this
YouTube time is when I'm meeting like a
lot of youtubers like so when I came to
LA in 2009 I meant like JK films and you
know wax and all these other youtubers
that are just doing their thing and we
just we're just kind of like hanging out
and they're doing their thing and I'm
like yeah I can't wait to like start
doing videos like this but didn't
understand the process behind it and so
I still was meeting youtubers in that
time and a lot of them jumped over to
vine yeah well this is well before vine
as I'm saying before vine I met I met
them and my spider-man thing I blew up
and this guy named King bat chat me up
like yo I saw your spider my video I was
like that's crazy dude I just seen your
videos last week and then we started
clapping on doing videos I did like
music videos for him I did like three
big music videos for him and we were
just hanging out all the time and I like
when I did the music videos I invited
all these different youtubers to his
video set so JK films they swarm and a
bunch of other people and then he
connected with DeStorm and they just
started shooting videos and they started
blowing up and I got school you know I'm
still doing this thing over here for the
television show yeah then vine came out
and they were like you know this one was
like yeah we should come shoot vines
wasn't like I come through and I just
started filming them
I just come through film it and oh my
god I see you guys later you know that
yo you're funny you should shoot vine so
that's where we first recognized where
we first recognized that you were doing
yes because I realized like you were
shooting a bunch of videos yeah cuz we
you did a project was based or him back
in like and it must have been 2011 it
was like one of the first videos we did
and then we just kind of followed him
you know yes doing and then yeah and
then yeah through that connection is how
he came to you and so like I wasn't I
I was doing this stuff for the YouTube
for the YouTube show that I was working
on so like I was just tagged breakdown
in it I'm like yeah if I'm gonna be any
just tagged breakdown
yeah and they sort was like bro you
should make your own channel I was like
mmm
now I'm I'm producing television
and I remember I'll never forget in a
month because bachelors just doing it
back back to back so I was like bro I
don't understand how you're doing this
man like you're just doing back to back
to back cool yeah he got a million
followers in a month yeah I'll never
forget and I was like yeah I'm about to
make my own channel yeah so I started
making my own channel and I sucked
I sucked for a very long time yeah I'd
say a year and a half to be exact I was
it was hard to get people to retweet my
stuff it was hard to get people to you
know like share my stuff it was just you
know me trying to do it and it was nice
black and woody and we were just
grinding it out all the time he spiked
woody lulu and layla used to come over
we just be shooting all the time yeah
and I just it would you know just be my
neighbourhood and we just started
gaining traction but like I wouldn't say
mine was like the best black had an
Android phone and we were just figuring
it out I remember when I first met what
he paid me 20 bucks to shoot a video for
him and I shot the video and I lost the
20 bucks and I really needed that 20
bucks
but yeah so what clicked on vine at what
point did you did you figure that format
yeah they would call my stuff well edit
it deletes cuz they'd always looked good
but it was just not funny yeah and then
yet at one point it just clicked and
then every video I was posting was
getting a million views well some sad
about it creatively making it simple
okay I'm making it simple so we I mean
like it was me bash lien at clarity
Melvin it was all of us just just we'd
have I could meet up said days for
himself said we'd shoot all day or I'd
be at my house would match I mean I
would against black and we'd shoot for
hours and we like me I'm so technical
with our he's trying to get like
different angles whippin and all the
stuff like that and then um you know
vine and uh you know obviously slowing
down and kind of like dying and I
recognized that I was like
this is you know like this isn't the
same you know like the popular pages are
the same and you know I was never up in
like the top ten Viners I was in that
maybe like the top thousand mm-hm and
you know it was just it was it was it
was tough because there's a lot of
talented people out there yeah that's
how we met Danny Gonzalez yeah oh so
good yeah so games because is through
that through that so that was what
clicked for you creatively though on
yeah making it simplicity of it is the
the one hit from the setup to the punch
line the punch line yep and that was
still like it's still like it's tough
you know but thankfully I got some you
know that really popped off and then
Instagram introduced their 15 seconds
and I was like great more time and so
that started doing really well for me
and then they introduced a minute I'm
like how great I think I'm gonna go to
Facebook so I went to Facebook and my
page hit a million in like four months
like I started you know taking my time
doing like more cinematic style content
and like just doing it my way you know
like sometimes when you're run a lot
people you try and do it their way and
you know you get caught up in like that
my instead of like all I can't do it
this way but I had to really get content
and comfortable with myself and the
things that I liked and I was like you
know I don't care I'm just doing my way
and I caught on yeah so I don't get a
million followers and it was like the
best day ever
you know they don't give you a plaque on
Facebook for getting a million followers
but my girlfriend she may want to shout
out to you brandy she's made me one and
it was really tight and that's where you
know I feel like life really started
changing for me yeah I started working
with a ton of brands you know producing
content for them that was going viral
and blowing up and it's just been great
so from that point I'd say like the last
three four years have really just on the
internet have been very successful I've
been very fun and I've had a lot of
opportunities to work with like a lot of
people that have always wanted to work
with in terms of studios and certain
companies
it's just been great and how did your
how did you create this process of all
from that from when you really figured
out the simplicity of what connected
with people on vine how did you
translate that into Instagram and then
over to Facebook and and how is that
really like a lot of people you know
they'll say like just be yourself and it
really is about authenticity like what
do you like your your unique perspective
on how you view things is different from
everybody else so people are gonna
gravitate the stuff they've they've
never thought of or seen before
you know like nothing nobody is ever
gonna think of the same exact thing the
same exact way and I and I love that so
I really honed in like I like cartoons I
like anime I like martial arts like
these are the things I like to do why
not just do the things I like to do as
opposed to try and like shift and curve
with like what's the trending topic of
the day or something like that like
that's not me yeah you know I could do
it's really easy for me to hop on the
trends of like I'm trying to think of
one that everyone did yeah there's so
many of them that everyone would do it
then you'll see a whole bunch of
different versions of those ice bucket
challenge yeah
ice bucket challenge whatever it is like
I could do those and like those will do
well but you know what do I really like
so I just
coned in on being authentic to like my
own voice things I like I retired from
doing music videos I absolutely refuse
to do this yeah because I just I like
you know when you're doing and working
for another company alright you know
you're kind of like your creativity is
at the disposal of what they want you to
do right and when I started working for
different companies operating from my
page they were like what do you want to
do you know what's your idea what do you
like well you're the distributor yeah
I'm the distributor and I'm like this is
way better I can just
I have creative freedom like maybe
they'll give me some guidelines but
outside of that I can control and create
stuff on my own and like it's just been
amazing it's a different world
so yeah that's let me hear ya now to
this day right I think well I think in
the lesson of that is like just hearing
that story I know you got to go soon so
but that this is what I took away first
and foremost you you learned the tools
yeah and that because people always ask
us how do you do it how do you what do
you do how do you get into it how do you
yeah how do you shoot stuff what do you
know all that and that's the first thing
is that you you started with the tools
both from like the camera standpoint and
then also just the grind to work work
work you know just that that process
you're just going through and meeting
people figuring out how other people are
doing things figuring out what's working
for them what's not working for them
yeah how that applies to what you want
figuring out what you don't want you
know and then really putting yourself in
a position with the education that
you've garnered from this experience to
take advantage of an opportunity when it
comes along big time you know because
it's like it's even like you what you
said with vine like the first couple
times you saw it you're like I don't
know maybe if maybe it's not for me
maybe it's for you it's working for you
that's great but maybe it's not for me
and then but it wouldn't it would be a
lot different if you had never touched a
camera they've never done anything
creatively and then all the sudden you
sat there and your buddies are making
vine videos that are blowing up and you
decide you want to do it too but you got
to start there
yep think of how you know think yeah all
the work you put in up to that point
allowed that yeah you had to like really
humble yourself honestly because you're
shooting on a phone and like I feel like
if you're a filmmaker you could shoot on
anything but like how they were doing it
was just it's a whole different style
but then you you know you're used to
shooting on like bigger cameras and I
got to do this onus a little phone yeah
like it's almost like traveling
backwards but at the same time it's it's
it's advanced right you know I mean it's
so crazy because there's no editing
you're you're shooting for the edit like
right and I've always been a believer of
shooting for the edit so alright I know
that a vine that
I need about eight clips at point six or
0.8 seconds yeah you know to tell a
story so I can fit a lot of stuff in to
tell a six-second sort of 6.5 second or
6.8 second story it's got to be all
right I want to get a medium on and get
a wide I want to get a push from this
way but you know and then I have to trim
do a gym leader a find way right and
right in there and then we didn't figure
out different ways to hack the phone to
get inside to download on the computer
early that way then backdoor uploaded to
the to the phone it was a lot of stuff
so like a six second video could
potentially take you eight hours right
you know and that's insane but like
you're just you're trimming you're
trimming you're trimming you're trimming
cutting the fat cutting the fat cutting
the fat
all right cool this is good what do you
guys think and you're in group chats and
people could be like that's trash or
that's heat I got a lot of like no
responses you know I just go back to the
drawing board to figure out different
ways and then when I got to Facebook I
can repurpose these videos make them
longer and really have a well thought
out idea so you found your style on vine
you went the Instagram into Facebook
from there and it was all sketches
sketches you know improving improving
improving and eventually you told me
before this conversation that Facebook
pick something up yet from you what is
that so I did I did a series of sketches
I did three of them they're called
couples night and they literally blew up
in like a day yeah I'm like 5 million
views I saw in a day and I'm like okay
this is crazy and then Facebook they
they kind of made me the they were
looking for influencers that you know
kind of encompassed like you know
directing producing writing acting all
in one and they're starting this thing
called the watch program and they
selected me as like the first
african-american face of Facebook for
their Facebook creator's app because I
encompassed all those things and they're
like hey do you have any ideas for a
series we're looking to onboard you for
our new program yeah and I was like well
I have this this series a day called
couple's night and I sent them a few
videos like great let's trick let's do a
trial run and you know release episodes
every Friday for the next six months and
they had to be a minimum I think of six
months every Friday
yeah Wow I think it I think it was 26
videos yeah Wow and I think it had to be
a minimum of a minute and 30 seconds and
I did it and they loved it it did well
and but I you know I discovered
something you know like one offs don't
really work in a series type form side
of revamped things they they react they
they've renewed me like three other
times
so I as that that happened I was able to
really like I like advance my way in
filmmaking in terms of like writing
scripted shows yeah
so I brought two buddies on Rome and
Paris to help me flush out these stories
and write write these scripts out fully
and I ended up creating like four four
episodes of season I did end up doing
six seasons but the first season was
like seven episodes of just one offs the
second season was four Episode four
episodes that I would condense into one
short film the third season was the same
thing and the fourth and for the season
were that same thing so by the fifth
season I did eight episodes and condense
into a 40-minute short film
really yeah so that was your first
chance to do something yeah scripted
basically yep first yester something
scripted and you know like I just got
better along the way so that was that
was an amazing opportunity just to like
get my mind wrapped around like what it
is to be a scripted show and like there
were no expectations besides make a
minute right and 30 you know like a
minute 30 video but I was making four to
seven minute short films and this was
like it's crazy to do that in a week so
I shoot I shoot it all in one day yeah
or I'd shoot it I take two days to shoot
because like the budget you know
wouldn't allow me just to do you know an
extended amount of shooting so I try
shoot as much as I could I did when one
night I did 30 pages one day I did 30
pages in like 12 hours and that's a lost
shooting about shooting yeah went all
the way through these are eight episodes
I did the whole thing and
yeah it was crazy I know we'd break it
down into like alright this is episode 1
except so - episode 3 but like I you
know I soon discovered I like to shoot
two cameras I don't want to shoot
anything less than two cameras so let me
just get this coverage yeah make sure I
get my wife's posture and but then
there's you know I've to do another take
let me do another taken it's hard
directing and acting at the same time
but you know I was able to achieve it
you know like learned to prepare better
you know to you know give myself
different options on takes there was so
much stuff going on but it was like it
was like an intense boot camp for where
my career is going next
yeah it burned me out after I did it
like I did that for an entire year and
it burnt me out so since then I've done
a few sketches but I really like Dovan
too much you know I need to like revamp
back up because it was literally myself
on the post and myself and two other
people doing all everything I had out of
music I - music guys I would provide me
for like the intro but yeah it was it
was crazy so to writers myself course
directing editing producing my special
effects guy and then another editor and
that was it and then then eventually I
was able to bring on a colorist yeah
very small team but producing like big
stuff in and getting you know
collectively about 15 million views I
wish you know I that's that's an
accomplishment but I'd like I would have
liked more but it's it's cool you know
like sometimes when you're rushing you
sacrifice quality just to get the
product out because my contract I had to
have episode out every Friday right and
it because I learned the first time
around I'm like you know maybe I
released this one on Saturday it's
supposed to Friday and you get penalized
meaning you don't get paid right a mic
well that's coming out of my pocket now
yeah so it was it was a very fun ride I
think my facebook for that for sure man
I think that just a point and point out
I think the process of that just quickly
is the that's what we're finding is
iteration is
I think iteration is gonna be king over
the next over the next few years here
especially with digital media I mean I
think traditional is gonna continue to
put out what it's currently doing and
and to keep those formats
yeah but man with digital stuff like
that's what we're finding is the more we
can iterate on a character or a style or
a genre or a story just the more the
audience likes it and wants to see more
of it and it you know you can create
these story lines or these pillars of
these are these features these shows
that that drive the rest of your content
yep exactly and it's it's been it's been
an amazing experience you know what
there's the show actually got me
nominated at first streaming my first
dreamy as Best Director suite and that
was pretty tight you know like it wasn't
anything I was expecting but uh you know
to be recognized after doing all that
hard work just you know like there was
no expectation fine it's just like I
just want to be better at this yeah and
to be recognized like that it was just
an amazing honor I was like this is not
anything I ever expected but it was
great dope new heights every day yeah
every day yeah man so with all that
taking into consideration what what are
the thing what's like the big thing that
that is is what you're getting into now
creatively and then you know where do
you see yourself in another year or
another five years and and what what are
you doing now to make that happen so
where I see what I guess I'll start
where I see myself in another year to
five years I've for sure will be
directing feature films like probably
the blockbusters that are going to
theaters
I'm 120 percent positive of that
it's a Sherm ran right there oh yeah I'm
a big believer in myself and speaking
things since existence and like I said
there's no plan B yeah
the Internet has just been a huge
foundation for me in terms of networking
making friends
seeing like the scope of creativity from
different individuals and trying to
bridge the gap between traditional and
digital so I've graduated the Sony
directors program I've shadowed on
several Fox shows I'm a you know meeting
and partnering with different people I
have a great partnership but RealD 3d
they produce you know you know 3d films
met with the CEO but with a marketing
team and there's a mutual love there in
terms of really like making their films
seem like the biggest thing on earth
I've partnered with Studios like
lakeshore entertainment I produce shorts
with them pitched you know they've given
me scripts to pitch to them what I think
what my direction is same thing with
other studios so they're consulting you
now on that stuff is like yeah because
that's the studio system is you got a
you got to work your way kind of
shadowing thing that the starters be
coming in as like a consultant on
different things
yeah and meeting and networking along
the way exactly and it's a beautiful
Brussels like every time I come on to a
studio a lot it's that like I said it's
that feeling it's it's the same feeling
from Full Sail same feeling from Japan
same feeling when I moved out to LA it's
a refreshing feeling where I'm just like
okay this is it like I know like
something's gonna happen here you know
like I know it I feel it and I'm just
like I'm always on the hunt for that
feeling and uh it's hard to explain but
I just know you know when things are
gonna heat up and even if they don't you
know like I'm I'm always very helpful
I'm always thinking big I'm always on
you know to the next thing like yeah if
it didn't work out like I'm all about
planting seeds sow seeds I've planted
over the past ten years
summer blossoming today like one of the
guys remember I worked at with Suzanne
to pass and Madison the lady who found
Michael Jackson there was a guy there
that was working there he was one of the
producers on that team he's the vice
president of diversity a so Nina so
that's the seed I planted ten years ago
yeah
and he's like what do you been up to
I've done this on the internet he was
like yo do you have any shorts to submit
to the Sony directors program right yes
I do and it was a thriller and it got me
into the program and that's parlayed to
so many other things and people that
have directed that went through that
program did moonlight did if Beale
Street could talk they're winning Oscars
like it's you know like so things are
working out and I'm moving into you know
I'm stepping into my purpose I'm walking
into my purpose every time I do
something linking with Paramount you
know there's a lot of people over there
that believe in what I'm doing and you
know it's a lot of speaking stuff into
existence and just really like love in
life you could attribute that that sort
of positive mentality to one or two
things in your life what would you what
would you fall back on for that I my mom
my mom my mom was always like she's
always been my biggest fan she's like
everything the philosophies I have on
just how to approach thing I've really
come from her you know speaking into
existence but the $10,000 hours in um
you know know you're worth like these
things have been you know monumental in
my life and helped me really just
they're like I like you know beats and
the script you know like these are the
beats that make sure I always hit you
know when I go into any situation when
I'm thinking when I wake up in the
morning like all right boom boom boom
boom boom yeah you know and like oh
she's dope yeah man she's dope so yeah
well she's such on your way and yeah she
brought me to Japan yeah brought me back
to this day you know and you know it's
she's been really great so well man I
hope you I wish you all the best of luck
and once again I thank you for coming
down here and spending this time with us
listen where can people find you you
guys can find me on everything at what's
good um corridor and what's good
sketches coming soon hopefully short
films and movies corridor you guys are
great
seriously like men I just got to start
sharing you guys stuff more because like
when I see it I'm just
this is what I'm talking about it's so
it's so dope so we'll hit us up and
let's do something else
absolutely man I can't wait I really
can't wait man all right cheers Cheers
see you guys thank you
huge thanks once again to Wes for coming
on and sharing his thoughts and views
and opinions and style it was a great
conversation you guys can also check out
more full episodes wherever you find
your podcasts or on the corridor cast
YouTube page and remember today's
episode brought to you top 10 games you
can play in your head by yourself
edited by our very own Sam Gorski I mean
I can't tell you enough about this book
if you if you've ever wondered what it's
like to be a trucker and to have to
survive and build a family business from
the ground up I mean this is the book
for you if you've ever wondered what
it's like to I don't know
explore space build your own spaceship
have you ever thought about this have
you ever wondered what is a dungeon
because it's not what it seems it's not
what it seems and you're gonna find it
all in this book right here turn your
mind and the ultimate gaming engine
that's right top 10 games you can play
in your head
amazon.com link in the description or go
to corridor digital comm you'll find it
there